Feel free to play around with the other data from that pole, maybe you'll find
a correlation between the number of eggs in your refrigerator and the number of
icons on your desktop. Some of them have missing data, so you'll have to adjust
for that. Out of these two that we analyzed in the lesson, we saw that only one
of them was significant, age and number of pets. We can see then that as people
age they tend to have more pets, that's kind of interesting right? But we can't
say for certain that the older you are more on time you arrive for a party, our
P value was too high. Let's focus on this one that's significant. Let's say we
add an outlier to the data, like 20 and eight. A 20 year old who has eight
pets. How do you think this will change the correlation coefficient? Go ahead
and add this data point to the spreadsheet, and find the new correlation
coefficient.